Okay.
So last time we started talking about conjugation,
the special properties that a functional groups have when they're adjacent to
one another in particular,
uh,
die.
Enes we talked last time about the Al Il system.
Uh,
the question is when does conjugation make a difference?
That is,
when is it simple enough and accurate enough to think in terms of isolated
functional groups with Payer Wise Adam interactions.
So we started with giving last time with giving experimental evidence that Al
Cad,
ion and ion and radical or all stabilized by something of the order of 13
kilocalories per mole.
And in fact,
the transition states when they're alloy lake are also stabilized.
And then right at the end,
last time you guessed for me and did the,
did the right thing to show that the dying at the bottom is special because it's
conjugated as opposed to the other deans.
So the heat that's involved in removing the double bonds is,
is less because it started out more stable.
But here conjugation is worth only about four kilocalories per mole,
evidently compared to 13 kilocalories and Al Lilly situations.
Another way of measuring it is to look at how difficult it is to rotate about
the single bond between the two double bonds in beauty dying.
So for confirmations we can have sin or sort of like eclipsed and Auntie.
And in between those there's a twisted form where the two ends are perpendicular
to one another.
And of course there's then no overlap across the middle.
The Pi says the two Pi Systems on the ends are orthogonal.
So you might expect that to the extent that conjugation is worth something,
the interaction of these pie things,
you'd lose it in this twisted form because they don't overlap.
So you might expect that the energy curve would look like that as we,
uh,
twist it.
In fact,
it's more or less like that.
But there's another factor which is up at the top left there,
you can see there's going to be repulsion between the groups when their sins.
So that's going to raise the left end of this plot.
So that's what it actually looks like as determined by Raman spectroscopy.
Uh,
okay.
So,
but the important thing is to look at how big the barrier is.
You can see the barriers about six kilocalories per mole in this case versus
about 60 kilocalories per mole for twisting the interaction between two p
orbitals across a single,
across the normal double bond and isolated double bond.
So the one between the two double bonds is 10 times easier to rotate than the
one that's involved in genuine double bond.
Even though when you look at it,
they're just four P orbitals in a row.
It's not immediately obvious that there's anything special about the one in the
middle that would make it easier to rotate than the ones at the ends,
which are,
we know to be hard to rotate.
Okay,
so why is conjugation worth more in Allah Lake Intermediate?
So the order of 13 kilocalories per mole than it is in dying where it's only a
handful,
you know,
a three to six kilocalories per mole,
uh,
one would be tempted to say it's because we can draw a reasonable resonance
structures.
In the case of an alcoholic intermediate,
those two at the top there are good.
They're equivalent to one another.
The one at the bottom is bad because we have to separate charge.
But that's not really a physical theory.
As we know the residents theory,
it is a very handy thing to,
to uh,
to remind us of what really happens,
but it's not what really happens.
We have to look at how the orbitals interact with one another.
So we're going to now having looked at some experimental evidence for the,
uh,
extent of stabilization due to conjugation,
we're going to look at the theory behind it.
Okay.
And we're going to work in terms of simple huckle ammos the,
the,
uh,
PowerPoint chooses that particular color to give links.
If you link there,
you can get,
uh,
a simple minded,
program to run on your computer that will let you make simple Hickle mos.
So,
uh,
Eric [inaudible] was a physicist,
the theorist,
and not long after Schrodinger develop quantum mechanics,
he began to apply it to some organic type molecules.
In particular,
the interaction of p orbitals with one another.
His brother was an organic chemist,
wrote a very influential textbook of advanced organic chemistry and no doubt
influenced him some in this interest.
Uh,
but it's a very simple minded theory as you might've expected from,
from being so soon after the,
um,
after shredding or developed a wave mechanics.
But anyhow,
uh,
these results are due to that.
And I don't think it's appropriate to take the time to go into the limitations
of the theory,
but let's just take it as a,
as a qualitative guide to the way things work in quantum mechanics.
Okay.
So suppose we have four P orbitals in a row.
There's the energy of an isolated p orbital.
Now there are two ways to look at beauty dying.
You can look at it as a whole or you can look at it as two double bonds and see
how they interact with one another.
And let's compare those two ways of doing it.
So first,
let's look at it as a whole.
You take those four P orbitals in a row and you combine them to make the best
possible,
uh,
molecular orbital psy one,
then the next best.
Then the next best,
then the next best,
right?
So that's what they look like.
And they have the what you would anticipate in terms of nodal structure.
The lowest one has no nodes except the note of the p orbital.
The next one has one node,
two nodes,
three nodes,
right?
But it's not,
there's a little bit more to it than that.
You notice that the best one is big in the middle.
Why?
Why are the P orbitals big in the middle rather than all of them being the same
size to get the best overall overlap?
Elissa,
what do you say?
Right?
The ones in the middle have to overlaps.
And in fact,
you can write a simple equation that will maximize the product of adjacent
orbitals.
That is the overlap subject to the sum of their squares.
Big One.
And you get that shape,
right?
So to maximize the bonding orbital overlap,
the central atomic orbitals are large inside one,
and for the same reason,
they're small inside to why should they be small?
Right?
Because the overlap in the middle is hurting you now.
So make it small,
get the overlap on the ends.
Okay.
Notice incidentally that three and four turn out,
they're not as good as they could be,
as as they could possibly be,
but as bad as they could possibly be here.
Or the one that's in the middle where it's favorable is small here.
The one where it's unfavorable is large,
that that turns out to be the flip side of,
do people know what flip side is?
It occurs to me that that's something that people might not know anymore.
When you had vinyl records,
you'd buy it,
buy a song.
That would be,
and there would be some other song on the back that wasn't very good.
Right?
So you'd play this side of the record.
That was the real what venue had the flip side,
right?
Which wasn't so great.
So the flip side of having these be as good as possible is those have to be as
bad as possible.
The bonding of the anti-bonding once.
Okay.
Anyhow,
there's a little cultural history for you.
So we have,
so we have four P electrons and they go into those two orbitals and get
stabilized.
And that's the energy.
Then the pie energy of the,
of the Buda dying,
that a four p orbitals in a row.
Now let's look at the other way.
Let's see if we just look at localized Pi bonds on each end.
How different is it?
Okay,
so we get two Pi orbitals,
one on each end,
two Pi Stars,
and the four electrons go down into the two Pi orbitals.
Right?
And what we want to do is see how that compares with the deal localized orbitals
on the left.
How different are they an overall stability?
Well,
let's analyze it this way.
We know that in fact,
we could mix these two with one another.
This is Pi plus Pi and Pi minus Pi.
So we're getting things that look a little bit like this,
but they're not distorted to optimize the overlap.
Okay?
And if we the ABS,
then these,
this goes down and this goes up the same amount.
That's part of the,
you know,
in truth,
that one that goes up goes up a little more than the one that goes down and goes
down.
Right.
But that's part of the hook.
All approximation is that they go up and down in the same amount.
Okay?
So the average is the same as where it started,
right?
But it's a little worse than it was on the left when we optimize things.
Now you can optimize things on the right too and see why it's not very important
to do this change in size.
Okay,
so here are the Pi Star orbitals that we got just by adding the two ends,
but now we can mix among these,
right?
So look what happens if we mix this one,
the two nodes with the no nodes,
right?
We can make it so it reinforces in the middle and cancels on the end and get a
thing that looks like that and that will make it a little bit lower in energy to
do that.
To mix this one with this one,
right?
We started with just isolated p orbitals and now we're letting them interact
with one another.
Okay.
To see how much difference it makes.
But this secondary,
the secondary mixing,
the first mixing was making these from here,
right?
The secondary mixing is minor because the energy matches so bad.
You don't mix very much of this into this one to get that or of this into this
one to get that.
Okay.
At the same time,
this one can mix with this one and that one will go down just a little bit,
but notice that the amount by which they went down is very small because of the
bad energy match.
Right?
Okay.
But then the ones on the far right or the same as the ones on the left.
If we let these interact with one another right into stages,
but that second stage,
the one that made it big in the middle and small on the ends here didn't account
for much energy because the energy match was so bad of the things we were mixing
and the same here.
Now you might say that that's it's,
it's only about three kilocalories per mole Max.
That's only the barrier to rotation of ethane,
right?
It's not very much.
Okay.
Now why did we ignore this mixing?
Because they're,
the energy matches pretty good.
Can anybody see why we didn't consider that mixing
there?
It might've been more important.
Yeah.
What's the overlap of this with this?
Notice that there,
despite the better energy match,
it doesn't lower the energy because these are orthogonal to one another.
They won't mix.
Right.
What is gained at two of the positions is lost that the other positions that is
if you adjusted on the left to be big in the middle and small on the outside on
the right,
it'll be just the opposite.
So you won't gain anything.
Okay.
So you,
you consider only this would mixing with that one.
This one makes me with that one and that doesn't count for much.
That's why you don't get much out of a dying.
Okay.
So although the total energies are nearly the same with and without conjugation,
that is the total energy that we calculate here is almost the same as the total
energy.
We calculate their,
there's just that few kilocalories difference.
Right?
But the energy of the homo and the energy of the Lumo are quite different here
from what they are here.
So if you're interested in reactivity,
then the conjugation makes a difference.
Right.
If you're interested actually what's not the total energy,
but the energy of the homo and the energy of the Lumo.
And also if you're interested in color,
right?
Because if you want to take one of these electrons with light and put it up into
the anti-bonding orbital,
it's a much bigger jump here when it's not conjugated,
that here when it's conjugated,
so you'll get the very different color and we'll talk about that later.
For example,
carotene,
the stuff that makes carrots,
orange is a bunch of double bonds in a row.
Okay?
Now,
so we see that when we mix these,
they go up and down,
right?
Is there a limit?
If we put a whole bunch of these Pi orbitals in a row as in carotene or
something even longer than that?
Can we do,
we just keep getting lower and lower and lower and lower energies for the lowest
energy?
So let's consider a few of these and just think about it.
The sort of approximately quantitatively.
So they're,
the chain length is too for ethylene,
right?
And the normalized atomic orbital size is one over the square root of two.
So when we square and some we get one.
Okay,
so the overlap when you have this one Pi bond is one half,
it's one over the square root of two here,
one over the square root of two here.
Multiply them together to see how,
how much they overlap,
right?
And you get one half in some units.
Now notice we're ignoring the small,
smallish inner influence of overlap on normalization.
Because remember when we take overlap into account,
we have to make them a little bit smaller,
a little less than one greater than one kind of thing.
We're ignoring that just to get an idea of what's going on.
Okay,
so the overlap is a half.
There's only one Pi bond in that case,
so we get a half times one.
The total overlap.
State stabilization is a half in these sort of weird units.
And notice that if you'd compare this with a textbook,
you'll see they use a unit called Beta,
which turns out to be half as big as this unit is.
But anyhow,
I think it's easy to go through it this way.
Okay.
Now suppose we have four in a row.
Now the chain length is for the normalized size is one over the square root of
four so that you could square in,
sum them up and get one.
And now the overlap between each pair of neighbors is one of the square root of
four times one over the square root of four,
right?
So it's one fourth.
Okay.
And there are three such bond interactions here,
here,
here.
So there are three times a fourth or three fourths.
So indeed it's more stable.
Okay,
that lowest energy orbital,
the one that's approximated like this.
Now suppose we have eight in a row.
Now the normalized atomic orbitals size is one over the square root of eight.
One eight is the overlap per bond.
And there are seven bonds.
So we get seven eighths is the amount of stabilization.
So it's going down,
down,
and obviously each time we add one it's add a pair.
It's going to go down more and more.
Is there a limit?
Is it chief?
Just that just keep going.
Obviously it'll get a little bit better,
a little bit better.
But does it approach a limit?
Can you see what it would be if n were infinite,
if the number that chain links were infinite?
Yeah,
it approaches one,
right?
Cause if you have n,
it's one over the square root of n and there one over n is the overlap and there
n minus one of these payers,
right?
So it's n minus one over n which approaches one is in gets very large.
So there's a limit to how good it can get,
right?
And incidentally,
that limit is twice what it started out here.
Here,
right?
It was a half and it approaches one.
And incidentally we also get bad combinations.
The Anti Bond,
right?
But it's exactly the opposite of this.
So the,
the worst anti-bonding combination,
right is,
is the destabilization is twice that of Pi Star,
right?
So these approach a limit,
and that suggests,
although it doesn't prove this construction that allows you to view what the
energies of the orbital will be in this simple approximation for any length of
chain.
So you draw a semicircle.
The vertical axis is the energy zero is a p orbital.
Here's plus one minus one.
Those are the limits if you have a very long chain.
But it turns out there's this geometrical analogy that if what you do is draw
this circle whose radius is twice the stabilization of the Po of the two P
orbitals in the Pi bond and has that limit,
and then you put points along this circle along the circumference,
evenly spaced along the circumference,
right?
It turns out that the height of the intersection of those points is the energy
that the energy of the various orbitals you can have.
So if you have just one p orbital,
you put it here,
equal distance between top and bottom and has the energy zero,
right?
So that's the energy of an isolated p orbital.
That was definition actually.
Okay,
now we take ethylene.
So we put two evenly spaced points along here to divide it into three along the
circumference,
right?
And now we can put two electrons in ethylene,
and that's the energy they'll have in a Pi orbital.
Okay?
It's a half halfway down here,
okay?
And now we take an equals three that's the Allina system,
but three equally spaced dots,
right?
And there are the energies in the alley or radical too,
in the two.
Two of the three p orbitals of the electrons in the P orbitals are in the lowest
energy molecular orbital and one is up here.
Now,
what's the stabilization compared to what?
Right?
Compared to what you had if you had just the Pi bond and a p orbital,
a radical,
how much better is it to have them next to one another and overlapping and an
hour they'll system?
Well,
you can see that if you had just a p orbital and a Pi Bond,
you'd have these energies in Allah.
You have these energies,
okay,
so that's the allelic stabilization.
Notice the,
the orbitals,
the electrons that got stabilized,
we're the ones in the lowest orbital in the difference between having them
separate and having them together.
And what that means is that it doesn't make any difference whether you have this
electron there or not.
If that electron is not there,
you have a cad I ion.
If the electron is there,
you have a radical,
if there are two electrons there,
you have the Alpha like an ion.
But in each of those cases,
the amount of stabilization you get is the same,
right?
So you get the same two electron stabilization,
whether you have cad,
I and radical or anti,
okay?
Now let's,
uh,
and incidentally,
when we look at this one,
remember that's just an isolated p orbital.
But in the alley,
all case,
it'll look like this.
It's the one with one node,
right?
Plus on one side,
minus on the other.
But that's going to be generally true,
however long the chain is,
right?
If you have an odd number,
odd chain here,
we had n equals three.
But if you had any equals five five,
you'd have blue,
nothing red,
nothing blue,
right?
And notice that in this orbital,
there's no overlap between the adjacent between occupied atomic orbitals,
right?
They're far apart,
so there's no interaction between them.
Therefore,
their energy will be the same as an isolated p orbital in this crude
approximation,
okay?
So every odd,
every odd chain is going to have at an orbital that has the same energy as an
isolated p orbital,
and it's going to have a node at every other carbon,
every,
every second carbon.
Okay.
Now suppose you have n equals four right now you have these energies for the
four electrons compared to this that you'd have if you had two Pi orbitals,
right?
So the favorable orbital is favored compared to the electrons in the orbitals
when they were isolated.
But this one is less stable.
It's the one that's anti-bonding in the middle,
remember?
But this one remember was big in the middle and this one we made,
and this one we made small than the middle.
So this one went down more than this one went up.
And the difference is the resonance stabilization,
right?
But it's not as big.
The difference between these two is not as big as how much those lowest two got
stabilized in Alley Hill.
So that's why conjugation is worth more in these aloe,
like intermediate,
like 13 kilocalories per mole than it is in a dying.
Because in the dying,
some go up in some go down.
Okay.
So as the conjugated chain lengthens,
more and more levels get crowded between minus wants.
Here's the limit of the lowest one.
There's the highest one and we're putting dots along here.
But as we put more and more,
longer and longer chain,
we're going to crowd more and more energy levels between those two limits.
So what that means,
the Homo Lumo gap is going to decrease.
So as we make it longer and longer,
you'll have this gap and then this gap,
this gap,
this gap.
Why did I draw it like this?
Why don't I use those colors?
Okay.
Has is the energy gets smaller.
It absorbs longer and longer wavelengths,
right?
So you can too in the color of a conjugated die in by how long are conjugated
Pauline,
by how long you make the chain.
And we'll see examples of that too is a good thing to talk about now because
very soon the spring migrant birds will be coming back to east rock park and
these beautiful tropical colors they've acquired.
And most of them have to do with that,
as you'll see.
Okay,
now let's look at heats of hydrogenation and conjugation.
So here's cyclohexane.
Here's cyclohexene.
The heat of hydrogenation to change this to that is 28 kilocalories per mole
gives off heat.
Okay?
Now let's take,
let's take two double bonds,
right?
And they're conjugated,
That turns out to remove both of those would go down here is 54 right?
That is the second double bond was taught worth 26 does everybody with me on
that?
Okay,
so 26 isn't as bad,
isn't as big as 28 that means this was a little bit lower than we would have
expected.
Why?
As it's conjugated,
right?
It's better than just to isolate a double bonds because they're conjugated.
The the lowest orbital went down a little more than the next one went up.
That's what we just talked about.
So of,
but that's not very much to write home about.
It says that conjugation is worth about two kilocalories per mole by this
measure right now let's put another double bond in the ring and tell me what you
think.
That's going to be,
what do you think the gap is going to be here?
Any ideas?
Let's get a couple of hypotheses out there.
Cassie,
what do you say?
Why do you say 24 why not 26
yeah,
it was,
it was a little bit less,
maybe a little less.
Again,
another reason it could be less again is this last double bond interacts on two
ends,
not just on one end.
So it might get to have those interactions,
right?
So maybe 24 maybe,
maybe.
Uh,
22 if,
if it,
if it depended on how we calculate that,
that would predict that we'd get about 78 the heat of hydrogenation of benzene
to give cyclohexane should be about 78 all together.
You know what it is experimentally?
right?
So this conjugation in a ring in benzene is really worth a lot.
Not just a little bit more because it,
you get the same thing on two ends,
but a lot more.
It's worth about 30 kilocalories per mole.
Here we were talking about two kilocalories per mole.
This is 30.
So this is a big deal and this is such a big deal that it has a special name
associated with it.
It's called Arrow Medicity.
The name originally had to do with the odor.
Benzene has a characteristic odor and other things that have benzene and um,
that,
that are volatile,
have a characteristic odor.
They were called aromatic.
But now the idea of [inaudible] is much more associated with this special
stability when you have a bunch of double bonds in a ring.
Okay?
Now,
so bringing the ends of a conjugated chain together to form a ring gives a
lowest,
uh,
lowest occupied orbital with another bond,
right?
We've got,
we've got all these P orbitals in a row.
Remember we made the,
the little bit bigger in the middle of little smaller on the end to optimize the
overlap.
But if we bring them around and touch the ends for no additional charge,
we get an extra bond here,
a whole new Pi bond.
So that's much more effective than just these little changes that are made by
adjusting the sizes.
So the lowest molecular orbital.
Now we'll have an of these overlaps rather than n minus one are you with me on
that?
Right when we had a chain,
the number of payers as down the chain was one less than the number of atoms.
But if we bring them to the leather together and let the ends touch,
then we get another one.
So it's an over and so it goes to minus one the lowest possible energy.
So a conjugated,
a conjugated ring,
the nodes as you go around the ring must come in and even number.
Let's look for example at the three membered ring.
So here are three p orbitals viewed from the top.
All right,
so there are no nodes obviously,
and the energy of that is going to be minus one on the scale.
The scale we were talking about,
right?
Each of these is one over the square root of three.
The overlap here is one third,
one third,
one third totals to one minus one and energy,
okay?
And there are no nodes,
but now let's suppose we want to make a node,
but now here,
here we have an energy that's a half.
It's the same as ethylene.
Right?
But notice we have a note we have,
we can't have just one note as you go around.
Cause if we go red to blue,
we have to go back and some place we're going to have to have another node as we
go around there to get back to the pink again,
you can't just have one node unless just to look ahead a little bit,
you twist it and make a mobius strip.
But that's quite a job.
We'll see that it has been done but it's quite a job.
Okay.
So anyhow,
the nodes come in pairs.
So there are two like that.
But the,
the other aspect of that,
I was going to say the flip side is that you get another way of doing the same
thing.
So you,
you could get two nodes here.
You can also get two nodes that way.
So there are two different ways to get two nodes,
right?
So you,
you have a lowest one and then you have a pair that have the,
there's one with no nodes,
then there's a pear with two nodes,
right?
And they have the same energy,
So now we can look at the energy shift that happens when you form one of these
rings.
That is how much is the era materiality worth?
Okay,
so there was Buda dying,
which we did already.
Now suppose we bring the ends together that were there was the lowest one and
now we have an end to end interaction.
So those interact with one another and obviously that's favorable and it will go
down and energy,
right?
Also they'll become of the same size.
Once you do that because it's no longer advantageous to have it big in the
middle and small on the ends because there isn't an end anymore.
How about that one?
When you bring the two ends together and let them touch what will happen to its
energy?
Ellen,
what do you say?
Pardon me?
What?
What do you mean decrease?
Well,
the energy go up or down.
When you touch the two ends.
Why do you say so?
There's another interaction,
but look at the interaction.
Look at the colors.
When you touch the two ends together.
When you bring,
when you bend it around.
So this touches that.
That's anti-bonding.
That's cute,
Huh?
Okay.
So that one's going to go up in energy.
Now how about the next one?
That one's going to be favorable,
that'll go down in energy and end up the same place.
This was,
remember there was a lowest one and then two pairs,
right?
Two which had a pair of nodes,
And the next one that's going to be unfavorable again.
Right?
So the structure when you bring the ends together is going to be different.
And fortunately there's a mnemonic device,
a geometric one just like this that works in that case as well.
Yeah.
And notice that the shifts alternate down,
up,
down,
and they must do that because of the number of nodes.
If you have an even number of nodes,
it'll be favorable because you'll have the same sign on the two hands.
If you have an odd number of nodes,
it'll be unfavorable.
So it has to be that down,
up,
down,
up as you go up the scale of Mos,
and then curled them to touch their end.
So when you bring the ends of the chain together,
the odd numbered Mos,
one,
three,
five,
decrease in energy,
those are the ones with an even odd,
an odd number of Cha,
uh,
odd numbers.
Therefore an even number of nodes because the very lowest one,
one has no nodes,
right?
Sorry for the confusion.
Okay?
While the even numbered ones increase in energy.
Thus,
if you have an odd number of occupied mos,
there'll be more going down than going up.
Is that clear?
If you have an even number of electron pairs,
there'll be down than up.
That'll canceled down than up that okay on sold down that up,
that'll cancel.
But if you have an odd number you have down then up then down,
there'll be more downs than up.
If you have an odd number of pairs of electrons,
so they're going to get overall stabilization,
special stabilization due to this Arrow materiality.
If you have an odd number of electron pairs,
of course,
you also have to take into account the sigma bonds because when you've been
things into a ring,
you may introduce rings strain,
like in the three member growing.
There's obviously that,
but as far as the Pi electrons go,
there's going to be special stability if you have an odd number of electron
pairs.
And this,
this gives rise to hook holes rule as it's called,
which is if we have four n plus two Pi electrons,
that's going to be unusually favorable in a conjugated ring compared to what?
Compared to a chain that's not touching the ends,
right?
Linear versus ring is going to be a specially stable.
If you have four n plus two Pi electrons,
uh,
that means an odd number of pairs.
So more of these going down than up when you bring the ends together.
And as I said,
there's a circle demonic.
Now remember we had for a chain,
we had a semicircle mnemonic for a ring,
you have a circle.
It's the same radius minus one to one is the limit,
right?
And now you inscribe a regular polygon with a point down,
because remember that lowest one is always going to have minus one is its
energy.
So the point's gotta be at the bottom like that.
Now we put dots on there for the energies we're going to have and notice they're
going to come after the first one.
They're going to come in pairs.
Okay?
So if you have [inaudible],
those are the energies you're going to have.
If you have two electrons.
So the cyclo pro penal catye in just two electrons,
that's the energy you're going to have had you had the alley ill,
the three or the three p orbitals in a chain rather than an a ring.
Then we already saw you'd have that.
So now we've got strong stabilization of two electrons coming down from here to
here.
Okay,
so there's a lot of aromatics stabilization of the cycle of propane.
Oh,
I right now,
suppose you had the radical,
the cycle of pro penal radical versus here's the alley or radical in the cycle
of pro radical.
Two of the electrons will be there,
but one has to be up there in one with two nodes,
right?
So this one is going up more than those who are going down,
but there are two going down here and one going up,
right?
If you have the anti and they're going to be two going up and that's bad,
okay?
You lose more here than you gain here.
Now remember,
there's always an emo at minus one.
So what Apps,
if we have Cyclo Buda dying for p orbitals,
right,
and four electrons.
Now there are energies,
there are the energy levels.
We put two,
we're going to put two electrons down here and one in each of those like that,
right?
And we're going to compare it with normal beauty die in which we saw before.
Has a pair here and a pair here.
Notice that these go up more than these go down.
So it's bad.
That's auntie aromatic.
This stabilization that we saw in benzene,
aromatic stabilization is the opposite here.
It's bad overall to put the ends together,
although it's good for the best orbital,
okay?
And notice also that these will be singly occupied orbitals.
So there'll be a little bit like free radicals,
right?
So this is going to be a very reactive species cycle of you to dying,
okay?
Now if you have benzene,
you have six and they look like that,
right?
And now we have six electrons to put in and we compare it with pexa trying as a
chain,
which has that.
And now you notice these went down a little.
These went down lot.
These wet up,
but not very much.
So this is where we got that 30 kilocalories of special stabilization had
benzene,
right?
A really good example of aromatic,
So four n plus two is the number of electrons in a ring that will give special
stability because there'll be more going down than going up.
Now that's interesting.
And it prompted organic chemists when this became,
although HOCAL did it in the,
in the early 1930s,
it didn't reach the consciousness of most organic chemists,
even though his brother was an organic chemist until the late 1950 [inaudible]
or 1960s.
And then people started trying to make all kinds of rings with P orbitals with
different numbers of electrons and see which ones would they,
could they confirm this rule?
And indeed they did confirm it.
Okay.
But much more interesting was how this same concept of cyclic conjugation,
uh,
applies to reactions and to transition states to make reactions faster or
slower.
And in that context,
we're going to talk about cyclo additions and about electro electro cyclic
reactions.
But first I want to mention also hetero aromatic compounds.
So you can have aromatic compounds that aren't just carbons in the ring.
Like for example,
nitrogen here.
Now,
think of the electrons on nitrogen.
It's forming sigma bonds to carbon on either side.
It has an unshared pair of electrons,
but that's not part of the Pi system that's in the,
in the plane,
right?
It's not part of the P orbitals,
which is what we're talking about.
It's an sp squared orbital,
but there is an electron in the p orbital.
That's incidentally,
this is redundant.
I drew a double bond here.
I'm also counting that electron.
Uh,
but that's,
it's actually participating in that double bond,
but I'm just showing it there to so that we can keep track of what Hetero atoms
are doing.
So there's a p orbital from a p electron from each of the five carbons apy
electron from nitrogen,
six Pi electrons,
four n plus two where n equals one on that stable.
That's aromatic.
Okay,
now few ran a five membered ring with oxygen.
Oxygen has two unshared pairs,
so it has two that are in the sigma system that are irrelevant for our purposes,
but it also has to in the Pi System.
So now you have one from each of the carbons in the Pi system too,
from the oxygen six all together.
Great Aromatic,
okay.
Parole.
Now the nitrogen has an unshared pair in that one.
So it's got one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six.
Good.
That's aromatic to unusually stable,
emit as soul.
This is a tougher one to count.
Okay?
One of the nitrogens has an unshared pair that's in the plane.
Don't count that one,
but it has.
The other one has a unshared pair that's coming in and out of the plane.
That's part of the Pi System,
right?
And there's a single electron on this nitrogen as there was over here.
So now we have one on each of three carbons,
four,
five,
six.
That's aromatic to admit as all.
Incidentally,
that structure is very,
it occurs in the amino acid histidine,
and that,
that's really interesting in that it is involved in long range proton transfer
and enzymes.
Suppose you have a proton here,
but where you need it is way over here.
All right?
What you can do is this,
right?
So this hydrogen goes up,
this hydrogen goes onto the ring and the ring sort of looks like it's turned
over,
right?
But a hydrogen has gotten up where you want it without actually having to move
the proton all that way.
Okay?
So these are all what are called Hetero aromatic compounds because they have
Adam's other than carbon in the ring,
but they're stable for the same reason.
We can look at the orbitals of fear and the one with an oxygen in it,
there's the lowest energy orbital.
It's what you expect.
P orbitals all overlapping favorably all around the periphery.
Uh,
no anti-bonding nodes.
But then there are two that have anti-bonding nodes,
right?
There's one that has an anti note at the back and in the front here.
So it's plus on one side,
minus on the other.
And there's another one that has an anti-bonding node that goes across.
So it intersects the rig both here and here.
So it's plus in back minus in front.
Okay.
And then you have the,
uh,
November.
There are,
uh,
there are six electrons in this.
So the two here,
two here,
two here.
These are the anti bonding orbitals and they,
as you can see,
have for each of them has four nodes as you go around the periphery.
So for example,
here,
there's a note on the oxygen and node between the carbons and node between the
carbons I'd noted between the carbons four nodes as you go around the ring.
And so these are a pair of the same energy.
Now if you want,
you can go to that,
uh,
that program you'd get on the web and,
and,
uh,
and draw crude calculations to,
to see this kind of thing.
So here's,
here's benzene,
right?
And here are the energies.
We're talking about a lowest energy orbital with a pair of electrons,
and then the next two right?
Degenerate as they're called pair,
and then anti-bonding and the worst.
Okay?
Now what happens if you put a nitrogen in the ring?
Now the lowest energy orbital is bigger on nitrogen.
Then on the other items,
why
anybody got an idea why it should be bigger on nitrogen?
Amy,
you've got an idea.
Yeah,
it has a bigger nuclear charge.
It's a better place for the electrons to be.
It's more electronegative as you say.
Okay?
And so it's lower in energy sea than it was here.
It's larger on the end and it's lower in energy.
Okay?
Now if we look at this,
the next orbital here,
what has two nodes here and here?
Right here was here.
It was in benzene.
Here it is in the nitrogen analog.
And notice it's the same energy here in here because it's the same orbital.
In fact,
what it is,
this is a Pi bond.
Here's a Pi Bond.
They don't interact with one another.
So the energy is minus one.
It's the energy of a Pi Bond,
right?
And it's the same here in nitrogen,
doesn't have anything to do with it.
But the other one,
there was another one here,
okay.
So those were identical in shape and an energy.
But there's another one that has the two nodes across the middle here and across
here.
And now it does involve nitrogen,
right?
So this one is high electron density on nitrogen and therefore a little bit
lower energy.
So these two orbitals that we just looked at that had two nodes where the same
energy here,
but different energy in purity.
One with nitrogen.
Now suppose you have 10 atoms in a ring.
Cyclo,
Deca,
[inaudible].
Here are the structures,
here are the,
uh,
the,
energies.
And now here's the lowest one.
Same as you go all around.
The next ones have a node here,
right?
That is two nodes as you go around the,
the periphery.
But notice these,
the right and left don't interact.
There's no orbital here.
So this is just like beauty dying.
And it's the same energy as Buda dying.
And same for this one,
which has the horizontal node.
Same energy here as they would have been in Buda dying.
Now the next one has four nodes as you go around and four nodes as you go around
right now,
Naphthalene is to benzene rings next to one another.
How can you go from this to Naphthalene to two six membered rings.
What you could do is take the atom that's in the middle on the top and the
middle on the bottom and pull them together.
So they overlap like this.
So then you have to benzine race together.
That's naphthalene right now let's look at the energies of that and see why they
come out to be the way they do.
So the very lowest one,
we brought this one to touch that one.
So we introduced the new bond.
Okay,
so it got lower in energy.
Okay.
And it's big in the middle as you expect because it has more interactions.
Now the next one,
if we take this one and draw the top and bottom together,
like that makes no difference because there are no orbital there.
It's on a node,
right?
So that has the same energy here,
here and here.
Right.
But if we bring the top to bottom together,
what's going to happen?
Yeah,
no.
What'd you say?
If I touch this to this,
is that favorable or unfavorable?
It's unfavorable.
So the other one will go up in energy to there.
Hi.
And now how about this one up at the top?
If we bring this to touch,
that makes no difference.
There's no orbital there when you have a node.
Right?
So that comes straight across.
But how about if we touch this to this?
No,
that's gotta be favorable.
So that one goes,
although that one goes straight across,
the next one goes down in energy.
So we can understand the special stability of naphthalene compared the Cyclo
deco pen.
Yeah.
And notice not only that,
but this,
this one which has nodes here and here has just isolated pairs of overlapping p
orbitals.
So it's the same energy as ethylene would be cause it's the same interaction.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now can you make that pub Cyclo deck of Pantene?
I'm going to quit with this one.
Okay.
And in fact,
it was made by Hyde street or wrote who was a postdoc here later,
but he did this in Germany with the module Fogel.
So they,
if you,
you can't make a ring that's that big without heavy,
enormous carbon,
carbon carbon angles and have it be flat.
But you could bend it in like this except for the fact that those two hydrogens
touch one another,
that's not good.
So one thing you could do is just make that a bond.
And we've already talked about that.
That's naphthalene.
That was the previous slide,
right?
But another way is to put a bridge across like as like ch two from this carbon
and this carbon so that those two atoms don't run into one another.
That will distort the periphery a little bit.
But it's,
we'll leave all the p orbitals around the edge.
So the way they made it was the first ad die chloro carby into a double bond in
the middle,
right.
Then remove the chlorine and now this thing could open that central bond to give
this and it does that.
Right?
And here's a picture of what it looks like.
So here's the ch two bridge across the middle,
but all around the periphery,
you have 10 atoms with P orbitals,
right?
And there's one of the orbitals,
and you'll see that's the one that has two nodes here and here.
So you have four,
five p orbitals here at five p orbitals here.
All right,
so now there's another criterion for aromatic city,
which is the chemical shift in Proton magnetic resonance.
And we'll see that,
uh,
next week.
Uh,
okay,
so that's,
uh,
there's actually a little more here.
I was hoping I'd get it,
but there's going to be like five minutes in the next lecture that will also be
on this exam,
but the next stuff will not be on the exam.
We're meeting this evening.
I haven't checked what the room is,
but I'll email you.
Okay,
thanks.